I'd like to pay tribute to Liz truss for  her dedicated public service to the  country  she has led with dignity and Grace for a  time of great change and under  exceptionally difficult circumstances  both at home and abroad  I am humbled and honored  to have the support of my parliamentary  colleagues and to be elected as leader  of the conservative and unionist party  it is the greatest privilege of my life  to be able to serve the party I love and  give back to the country I owe so much  to  the United Kingdom is a great country  but there is no doubt we Face a profound  economic challenge  we now need stability and unity and I  will make it my utmost priority to bring  our party and our country together  because that is the only way we will  overcome the challenges we face and  build a better more prosperous future  for our children and our grandchildren  I pledge that I will serve you with  integrity and humility  and I will work day in day out to  deliver for the British people